hey what is up guys I'm KB HD here and
this is the late 2013 early 2014 Mac Pro
and yes it is very very small see this
is a weird little desktop from Apple so
for the past decade or so Apple has been
slowly moving away from the pro market
from their software all the way through
to their hardware PC sales have been
slowing down their iPads and iPhones
have become way more popular and
money-making and there's just really not
that much money in professional
workstation grade machines anymore and
for a while Apple just straight-up
ignored the whole pro market and for
years never updated the Mac Pro until
now and about 1 so this review is
actually coming from a bit of a
different perspective versus the typical
Mac Pro buyer the normal Mac Pro buyer
from maybe 2007 up until the latest
generation before this one would have
the Mac Pro sitting dormant in a corner
of a studio somewhere and would use it
to power their displays for music
production or video production or
whatever they do the typical Mac Pro
buyer doesn't use it as a full-time
workhorse and everyday machine so that's
where my review is coming in as someone
who's actually going to be using this
everyday for stuff like you know web
browsing the typical everyday light load
stuff and I also happen to do some
production as well so that's the way
this review is sort of framed so the
main thing about this new Mac Pro is its
size obviously it's much smaller than
not only the previous generation Mac Pro
but really any other desktop computer
let alone a high-end one it's really the
only desktop that you can hold like this
at least I'm pretty sure it is anyway
but the thing is that doesn't really
matter much I mean it's a 10 inch tall
11 pound cylinder that in theory you
could put in a backpack and bring
wherever you want as a sort of a
portable studio with you but that is a
very very small group of people actually
doing that plus you need to monitor
anyway but Apple is still very proud of
how small they've made this machine they
talk about it all over their site and in
all their promo material and you know
that that that is pretty impressive
still it's smaller than some full-size
graphics cards it kind of forces itself
on your desk with that shape and
reflective aluminum shell
of course because it is this small it
makes the cooling situation pretty
interesting now as far as heat and noise
and thermals go Apple in general has a
long history of cooling things as little
as possible
mainly because apple hates moving parts
I mean you don't have to look very far
in other Apple products to see that so
as far as fans go there is just one
single fan cooling every component in
this workstation great desktop I'll say
that again
there is one fan cooling this whole
desktop now it is small and there is a
lot of hype about it but it's what they
call the thermal core and it actually
does a surprisingly good job so the way
the thermal core works is this you
essentially have all the components of
the Mac Pro in this case that's the
graphics cards the terabyte of flash
storage the eight core Xeon processor
and all the RAM the motherboard
everything all up against the three
sides of the prism on the inside it
looks like a triangle from above and the
center of it is empty and this is where
the air flows from the bottom to the top
cooling all of the parts with the same
airflow so these vents you see on the
bottom of the Mac Pro yeah you do not
want to block those because that is all
of the intake that's where it's in
taking all the cool air and the single
fan we talked about is up top sucking
air through the whole system and because
it's such a large fan it actually
doesn't have to spin very fast to move a
lot of air and actually found the
thermal core to be really effective it
kept the system at a reasonable
temperature pretty much no matter how
hard I pushed it and video editing with
Adobe Premiere and After Effects I
really got the fan to spin up I mean the
thing is pretty much silent strangely
the only time I could actually get the
fan to spin loud enough to even hear it
and it's three feet away on my desk
was watching a bunch of YouTube videos
in a row so thanks Adobe Flash anyway
this thermal core is such a boss at
cooling it works so well that
performance on this mac pro is also
fantastic it all just flies through mac
OS 10 mavericks as you would expect i
mean it costs a pretty penny you would
expect it to fly through its native OS
and it does i've had absolutely no
hiccups it outperforms the hackintosh
pro I built it flies through apps like
no other machine I've ever owned
and it's an absolute breeze to use
during everyday single-threaded tasks so
that's good news now personally when I
get to the more heavy stuff take
advantage of all eight cores like I
mentioned I use Adobe Premiere and a bit
of After Effects like I said for video
editing and these apps are clearly not
optimized for this new hardware because
I actually don't really see a difference
in performance between the Mac Pro and
the hack Pro I built and used for so
long some of this has to do with the
fact that it's a beast of a workstation
GPU not a regular gaming graphics card
so the d700 Adobe just doesn't know how
to talk to them yet and really it's up
to Adobe at this point to get this
system in their hands test it optimize
it for this new hardware and push out
the updates to all of us Mac Pro users
because I would love to see the
improvements that Apple's Final Cut
users are seeing on this Mac with the
Adobe suite but either way I'm not going
to drill through benchmarks again for
that I will refer you to the Mac Pro
performance review video that I did
it'll be linked right below that like
button if you want to check out how it
compared against my hackintosh pro and
another Mac that I've used also another
youtuber Armando Ferreira put together a
PC for the same budget as this Mac Pro
and ran benchmarks of his own on that
side so of course it's still running
Windows but with that video also linked
below you can get a better sense of how
you'll do with the price to performance
ratio now another thing you have to talk
about is the i/o on the new Mac Pro
because it's a little bit different from
the old Mac Pro but it's also very
different from most other desktops as a
workstation you're getting four USB 3.0
ports you're getting six Thunderbolt 2.0
ports you're getting two ethernet jacks
and you're getting hdmi 1.4 that is it
now actually have a seven port USB 3.0
hub that I used I don't think USB
expandability is a problem but that
brings us to the biggest difference
between this Mac Pro and the old Mac Pro
not just the size but that's the
difference between the words
upgradability and expandability this new
Mac Pro is a hundred percent upgradable
which you can't actually even say about
the old Mac Pro but it is not internally
expandable you have to expand through
thunderbolt 2.0 and if you can't get
what you want done through thunderbolt
2.0 this machine is not for you
this is going to affect a lot of people
who are using PCI based solutions like
they were on the old Mac Pro there are
no open PCI ports in the new Mac Pro so
if you want something like a red rocket
or a new video card or something like
that it has to be done through
Thunderbolt right now that situation
doesn't look as promising or as friendly
as we might want it to be but hopefully
in the near future there's way more
Thunderbolt accessories that were
previously PCI accessories so at the end
of the day is the Mac Pro a good buy
right now it's not going to seem like a
good buy because you know the Adobe apps
aren't optimized there's a whole bunch
of things missing in terms of expansion
and it doesn't really look like a
complete package and people aren't
exactly throwing away their old Mac Pros
or IMAX
who are working on production just yet
those will still have their place in the
studio but for me as a person who's
using it as a full-time machine as a
person who uses it every single day and
also does production I feel like it's
been a really great investment and of
course there's a whole bunch of
different Mac Pro's the four core the
six core the eight core and the twelve
core I feel like I did actually make the
right choice as I explained in the
performance video with the eight core
Mac Pro as a sort of a balance between
single threaded and multi-threaded apps
so basically there's going to be a ton
of overpriced trashcan jokes we already
know that people who haven't made it
this far in the video probably have
already left that comment below but the
idea here is it's got a future ahead of
it there is not going to be another new
Mac Pro for probably ten more years as
we've seen with the old Mac Pro in the
history of the way Apple has updated it
so you know come back to me in 2018 and
maybe we'll have a totally different
story to tell about this new interesting
innovative small compact Darth Vader
looking machine that we call the Mac Pro
either way that's been it thank you for
watching hope you enjoyed this review
video again I'll leave the links to the
performance review I did of the Mac Pro
and of the unboxing and first
impressions down right below that like
button if you want to check them out
thanks for watching
I'll talk to you guys in the next video
peace
member